In this talk, we want
to go high level.
And we want to describe how we
envision the future of Shiny
and what we do to
fuel that future.
My name is Filip.
I'm the CEO of Appsilon.
And together with me,
we have Marek, our CTO.
So we want to share what Appsilon
built to empower everyone
to create a
spectacular Shiny apps.
All right, so if
you're still with us,
I think we can guess that you
love Shiny just as we do,
and I personally
believe that Shiny is
a unique piece of technology.
It empowers thousands of
scientists and data scientists
worldwide to share, to
first to create, and then
to share their analysis
and useful tools easily.
Through the years, we've
seen some unique examples,
some crazy ones starting
from native iPad applications,
through software as
a service Shiny apps,
and ending up with offline
Shiny applications
on and on and on.
Just through the
pandemic, we created
free, publicly available
dashboards, which
were mentioned in the press.
And on a given day they
received significant traffic.
So I think that
it is clear by now
that Shiny is ready to be
used in different environments
enterprise environment,
internal environment,
external environment, and is
being used by governments, NGOs
and businesses.
But if your app is not
basic, if it's not simple,
your success is at risk.
And there are
certain constraints
that every person that works
with Shiny needs to be aware of.
There are technical and
operational challenges
waiting for you ahead.
And we've seen some
great apps fail.
And if it's navigated
correctly, these challenges
can be resolved,
risk can be avoided,
and we think that
here we've identified
what makes Shiny successful.
So
if you want to make
a successful app,
you need to make sure that
people are going to use it
and to be happy to use it.
Right now, people really don't
want to use slow or not great
looking Shiny app, or
any app.
People's expectations are very
high regarding the front end.
And I'm not saying your
application is ugly.
I just say some applications are,
and that the better it looks,
the easier it is to use, the
higher the chances of getting
buy in from the people
who are going to use it
at the end of the day.
And we've seen some
teams building apps
for many months
struggling to get
to have an impact and apps
being bigger and bigger, slower
and slower, and apps getting
harder to maintain every day.
Of course, we also
see teams which
manage to create great apps.
It is possible, but it's
not always straightforward.
And also, very often
it is not expertise
of this certain people
to work in such a way.
So either you seem
to be either aware
that they might lose
speed of development
because it's hard to maintain
or they need to gain expertise
in other domains, which
are not their main domain.
On the other hand,
our background is in,
Appsilon was founded by
people with backgrounds
in applied mathematics
and software engineering,
and we are attracted
to R, we are attracted
to Shiny as software engineers.
And we think that this
is something we bring to a
diverse community
of R world, and we
want to embrace our
backgrounds that were built
through the years, many
different Shiny apps,
we resolve many
different problems,
some of them taking months
to getting resolved.
And we think that
we can share what we achieved.
We believe that
our background in software
engineering and our tools
that we've created can help.
Can be our way to contribute
to our community, and this way,
we can empower scientists,
researchers, data scientists
worldwide to create
spectacular apps themselves.
We believe that this way
more apps can be created,
they can be created faster,
and also together, we can
encourage more people
to try R and Shiny and kick
start their journey.
This is one slide that
I showed during my talk at
UseR conference in Toulouse,
and at that time, I kind of
embraced advantages
of Shiny when
compared to different
technologies and alternatives.
But
I think that solution to
building better Shiny
applications also
lies in these
other technologies,
and as much as we
have some advantages,
we also need to recognize that
certain other technologies can
teach us, how can we do better?
So with with our mission
statement being said,
which is to empower
data scientists to create
the spectacular Shiny apps,
I will hand off now to Marek to show you
some work that we've actually
put into fulfilling
this mission and also
to discuss our progress
so far.
Thank you Filip, so I'm very excited
to share with all of you
these new developments
that we will be releasing.
And if you have any questions,
ask them in the questions
section, and we will
be happy to answer.
So a great UI is something
that takes your Shiny app
to an
entirely new level.
And we have heard
great talks today
from Tom and Shannon on
bslib and the theming
from Pedro about
custom styling
from Dominik, who mentioned
lots of Shiny extensions.
And so so there are a lot
of great options already.
However, looking at
what is available
and other technologies,
they have not only
bootstrapping
semantic, for example,
and actually, there are tons of
libraries for user interfaces
and so on and
not all of them are yet
easily available for us in Shiny.
So so we are changing
a part of that today
with two new packages which are
shiny fluent and shiny react.
And the main thing
I want to talk
about today is shiny fluent.
So shiny fluent lets you use
Microsoft fluent UI and Shiny.
But what is fluent
UI from Microsoft?
First of all, so fluent is a
UI library from Microsoft that
is used a lot in their software.
If you use fluent UI
in your app, it
can basically look like
Microsoft Excel or Outlook.
And so on.
So this means that your app gets
a nice professional look, which
is a great fit, particularly
if your users are
in large companies,
and especially so
if your company is already
using Office and, for example,
PowerBI a lot.
So we've seen Shiny compete
with Power BI quite a lot.
And almost always one of
the points in favor of PowerBI
was a better interface.
So today
we want to bring this to Shiny.
So let me open another page.
Right, so everything you see
here is a Shiny application,
it's completely
coming from Shiny.
And this is built using fluent UI.
This is actually a part
of our documentation.
So you can browse
all the components
that are available
in shiny fluent,
the various kinds of
buttons, for example.
It's very configurable.
So you can really have a
lot of room in defining
easily using parameters
the appearance
and the behavior
of those buttons.
You have you have lots of cool
stuff like contextual menu,
nice, nice looking lists.
I really like some
of the features
that fluent provides
for guiding your users
through the application,
especially for the first time,
like coach mark, that
can appear and contain
some explanation and
of course, there are
nice, nice dialogue, windows.
And so on, just all
of it looks nice
and so powerful and
configurable. And so also shiny
fluent has a lot of components
for which often in Shiny, we
used to have to pull in other
packages like custom packages
to have some
kind of nice input.
So a lot of this is
already available
within fluent and
via shiny fluent in Shiny.
So there is one
problem, though, here,
and it is that fluent
is based on React
to get all of the appearance,
you need to render it by React.
And that's why we built shiny
react, which brings React to Shiny.
And the story of shiny react
starts when you thought just
about how cool it
would be to have
a reliable and
efficient way of using
all the richness of the React
ecosystem in Shiny.
Just think of it.
There's so much.
And great stuff.
There's so much great
stuff available in React.
Like all the framework,
materialUI, blueprint, fluent,
and tons of components for
charts, maps and whatnot.
And also one thing
that is super important
is that Facebook's team
has put a lot of effort
into improving its performance.
So it's really fast.
So it can make also
our Shiny apps faster.
JavaScript developers have all of
this because they use React.
So we should have that, too.
So in one sentence,
shiny react aims so that
you easily use
React libraries in Shiny.
And I'd like to thank the authors
of a package that was available
earlier, which is reactR,
especially for some
of the ideas that they have in
their package, which helped us
and our scenario and our goal.
It didn't work for us due
to some of the limitations.
And one example
here is that reactr
seems to be focused
more on making
the porting
individual components.
Or just a few components and not
necessarily entire UI libraries.
So what's special
about Shiny react?
It's, first of all, you
can port entire libraries
and it's easy for Shiny app
developers like the inputs
that you get that are
pretty close, as close as
possible to the Shiny API
that we are used to.
I think that was quite,
quite challenging to achieve
is to give the ability
to mix and nest Shiny
in React and inside
of Shiny again
as the outputs from Shiny.
And so on, so that we can still
use all the Shiny components
that we are used to.
It also provides documentation
for the components coming
from the original packages.
But inside the R documentation
system, which is very useful,
and basically solves a lot
of practical challenges
that you just don't
have to think about.
So this is what
made shiny fluent possible,
and I'm excited to see
what other libraries can
be made available this way.
But let's go back to Shiny fluent.
So this is a most basic app.
And what's special here is
just you just use the library.
So we load the package shiny
fluent and then
you just have to wrap
your code and work
with the reactant function call.
And inside, you can
use all the components
that are taken from
fluent, that you can
use all of their properties.
And so on.
So basically this code gives
you these two nice buttons.
But so that you
fully believe me,
I would like to do a quick live demo.
So this is an application
that we built just
in a couple of hours using
fluent UI, it's again, all Shiny.
So a scenario that we
picked is that, let's say
we want to analyze how our
sales department performs
and which sales reps, sales
representatives perform best.
So you can see here all
those nice inputs that I
think are very, very just
pleasant to use, it's
always an issue.
So I really like how
they solve this in fluent.
The really nice components
like this people picker,
which can show you a lot
of details about the
the people that you pick.
Really nice list view.
But
what's also interesting
is that what you
can see here, this
is a regular leaflet inserted
with a leaflet output,
but this leaflet output is
inside an entire structure,
which was put here not like
we used to do, but by react.
So it's not obvious that
this works, believe me.
So this is really
cool that you can
show that you can embed
what we already have
in Shiny inside react.
And then the same here
with this block, that block,
and so,
so this is a truly live demo.
Let's try to make a
change to this app.
Add some functionality.
Let's see if we succeed.
So let's say we want
to filter this list
of deals closed
by the sales reps.
We want to filter
out to the smallest
deals like the minimum limit
for the amount of the deal.
So we can use,
let's find some
component that we want to use.
So we can pick
slider, for example,
and we can see that
slider is just,
we just need to insert
a slider and give it
an id, as is usually in Shiny.
So let's do that.
Let's go to RStudio.
So we can go to where
the filters are.
This is our UI code.
Right, so we have the slider.
There's a lot of
configuration options, so
and you can just type
type question mark
slider, and then you
will get that in
the documentation window,
all the options
available. But let's say
we define the step of 100,000.
And we give a label, we can
configure how to format that.
Right so this gives
us already an input
that we can use in
our server part.
So now what we need to do
is just to filter the items.
The items based on
the input value.
And that should do it.
First pick up.
Right and we have
the slider here.
So I think it looks
really nice, it's just a
really beautiful slider,
it can be beautiful.
I just really like how
it moves anyway,
it's very consistent
with the entire look.
We could add
something else here.
Now as you can see, we can filter
out just the biggest ones.
So back to the presentation.
So the good news is that all
of this will be open source.
And we will be releasing this
in the just in the coming weeks,
starting with an
early access group.
So if you're interested, please
fill out the master class
feedback form.
The link will be at the
end of this presentation
and make sure, there
is a checkbox, which
you can check, to and be in
their early access group
for shiny fluent.
So make sure to do that if
you're interested in that.
And you can already today
open up the demo at this URL.
All right.
And so the second area
that I want to cover
is developer tools.
So you may have
seen Olga's great talk
about best practices
and just about before.
And what she did was, she
showed a lot of best practices
that we use in the community.
And she did this in a
non opinionated way.
So that no matter what were
there were some examples,
but no matter what
technology choices you make,
you can still use
these best practices.
There are a lot of
options. At the same time,
at Appsilon we are building
projects and development
workflow tools that realize
these best practices in a very
opinionated way, which
is, in our opinion,
just works best
for most projects.
So today, I'd like
to share with you
that we will be publishing,
the first of its kind Shiny
application framework.
So I think that on
top of Shiny and let you
be more efficient for
building production apps,
so there are a lot of areas
that you can take care
of to make your app work
well in production.
You don't necessarily have
to take care of all of them.
Bu if you do,
it really, really
increases your
chances of success.
So over the years, we've built
tools for all of these areas.
And in the coming months, we
will be gradually sharing them
as a unified framework.
So why does this matter?
Basically, all of the points
from the previous slide matter,
because ultimately
for appss that work
in production, that users,
your users depend on them.
And we need to ensure
that they're, first
of all, reliable and easy
to maintain, but also
for our projects
to be successful,
we need to do that to
achieve maintainability
and reliability while keeping
the development velocity high,
which like keep the philosophy
that Shiny is famous for.
So just some
examples of what you
will get with the
framework out of the box,
much richer domain driven
application structure
and tests.
Like on this example of cypress.
Comprehensive but easy to
use dependency management
like Olga mentioned.
Data validation.
So what's really new here
compared to existing solutions?
I think there are
three main things.
First of all, it's a
complete framework,
a complete ecosystem covering.
Giving you an option
for all of the points
that you need to think of.
And then it's just,
the fact that we
bring best practices
from other
technologies and areas
where we're as the
Shiny community, we
can benefit most by learning
from other technologies
and the third.
You get all these
best practices, not as
knowledge, but as code, so
you can start your project
from scratch with all the
best practices included
and you can learn watching,
which parts you need,
like you can learn
each part that you
need from the code that is
already in your project.
And it's already working.
And you can learn from that.
Right so back to Filip.
So.
A workflow.
And shiny fluent
and shiny react are
going to be fully
open source, and we
are excited to share our
frameworks and our way of work,
but we think that sometimes
frameworks are just not enough.
They don't cut it on their own.
And this is why we want
to create another resource
for our community.
So in other
communities, if you
want to create your
WordPress page,
if you want to create
your e-commerce store,
if you want to create your
study bootstrap website,
you can gross,
I bet, thousands, maybe
hundreds, depending
on the use case, premade
quality templates and layouts.
You can choose, pick the one you
like, you can download or buy
and customize with a fraction
of work necessary to build
everything from scratch.
And this is why we
we decided to do the same
thing for the R and Shiny community.
So, we decided to
share some of our work,
and our Shiny apps are often
complimented for how they look
and we are quite proud about
taking care of a great design.
We deeply care here about
apps being both easy to use
and beautiful and useful.
So some of the layouts that
were crafted by our engineers
and designers are
going to be available,
some of them for free, some
of them to buy on the platform
that we are going to
share with everyone.
So what did we promise today?
First, shiny fluent
and shiny react
are going to be
open source, you can
create great enterprise, great
applications especially
for enterprise ecosystems
with shiny fluent,
and we should expect
more React
libraries is being
part of it, as R
packages available to us.
Second, we will open source
a lot of our internal tools
to empower the whole
community and to leverage
what we've discovered
in many of our projects.
So that the whole community
can move forward much faster.
At least we hope so.
Third, we will help kick start
hopefully more teams and
more Shiny developers,
that want to work with
premade templates and layouts.
All this, we do because we
want to empower data scientists
and scientists and researchers
worldwide to create
more and better Shiny apps.
So that together, we
can have more impact
and help other people make
wiser decisions with the data.